[Music]
you led me straight to the lost city now
prepare to die there are just hundreds
of snakes in this temple just waiting
for us to show up what why aren't they
biting that guy this is ridiculous
delete delete delete
listen loretta we need you to promote
your new book on the lost city you can't
spend your life in the bathtub drinking
chardonnay with eyes
ladies and gentlemen the world's sexiest
cover model
mcmahon
you do know you're not dash right dash
is a character i made up yes oh my god
crap
miss sage i enjoyed your book about the
lost city and i believe you're the one
who can help me find its treasure
i have to respectfully decline i'm
afraid i must insist
unchain me that's your seat belt
loretta sage is missing i'm gonna rescue
her i just want her to think of me as
more than a cover modeling dangerously
alan what are you doing here we're here
to save you i'm certified cpr i'm sort
of like crossfit
i have snacks after them
this is like your book we're on the love
more and dash adventure right now i'm
gonna help you out a little bit go what
are you doing don't do that
get out of there this is not a romance
novel jungles eat people like us what is
that get it off
i can feel them suckers
feels like there's more holy mother of
god ah
we're so close i could actually find the
lost city
if i don't get to this island my friend
and her cover model are going to die i
am driving oh
loretta sage getting you out of here why
are you so awesome my dad was a weather
man
hey oh she doesn't need saving in there
uh what are you doing in there
[Music]
so
[Music]
bye